back at the LPGA Classic Zoey
Papadopoulos a very promising career
that has gone a little wayward of late
she now has three feet to force a
playoff I would hit the loop again oh my
word the worst display of sportsmanship
this is a complete meltdown
[Music]
don't worry about this golf it is
nothing
I'm going to finish polishing Monday go
get the jury if I can't putt I can't
play there's no more chore for me
crappy nice if you're Sully so-called
hesitate say Ana pristine okra CV then
in a telescopic antenna Granth Rocky
Yasu Mila Selena [ __ ] I do but I thing
you don't Oh Stella
nice to meet you Stella why aren't you
playing on a golf course you have to pay
another money to play I didn't pay a
small fortune to have my own private
golf course I wanted to make some money
so you explain to me how I'm supposed to
make some money when there's none what
does a golfer out here oh are those
sheep really I won't invite you to run a
golf cleaning for the summer
I'm not your stag if we can make a deal
charge tourists and out-of-towners
anything you want I don't care but
locals play for free deal
[Music]
what's going on here Pato next time I
come back here I want to see this place
filled with paying gold
he doesn't own a goth right 0:02 little
village is about to become the 5-star
Golf Resort and maybe you could find
yourself a job flipping burgers in one
of the four side cafes
and the Sun cannot go through these lats
unless we allow it I want to thank you
for your kindness towards my daughter I
don't know how to explain it but game
means everything to me
see the shot in your head take a deep
breath and swing away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you